en este vídeo voy a jugar con la
derivación implícita la cual me va a
ayudar a entender mucho mejor la regla
de la cadena o viceversa lo que sí sé es
que por un momento voy a dejar de lado
todo lo que tenga que ver con x de fx y
voy a utilizar nuevas variables para que
se den cuenta que es lo mismo en esta
ocasión me voy a tomar la siguiente
función voy a decir que am es igual a b
cuadrada y en esta ocasión voy a tener
una segunda función mi segunda función
va a ser que b es igual al seno de c
ahora bien lo que me voy a preguntar en
este vídeo es quién es la derivada de a
con respecto a si bueno atrás de esto es
lo que voy tras la derivada de a con
respecto a c como puedo encontrar la
derivada de a con respecto a c y bueno
para resolver esta incógnita lo que voy
a hacer es tomarme la regla de la cadena
hemos trabajado bastantes veces con la
regla de la cadena y bueno que desde la
regla de la cadena que la derivada de a
con respecto a c pues es lo mismo que la
derivada de a con respecto a b
y a esto multiplicado por la derivada de
b con respecto al ser y se dan cuenta no
hay mucha magia en la regla de la cadena
es simple sencillamente una
multiplicación de fracciones es la
derivada de a con respecto a b y la
derivada de b con respecto a c
el numerador y el denominador se
cancelarían vamos a hacerlo con calma
esto va a ser igual a las diferencias de
a que multiplica a la diferencia al debe
y está dividido entre la diferencia
aldea no no no perdón entre la
diferencial deben que multiplicada
diferencial de s y se dan cuenta una
diferencial debe que multiplica y una
que divide a esteban es decir esto lo
mismo que la de experiencia aldea entre
diferencial de s o dicho de otra manera
la derivada de a con respecto a hace es
lo mismo que me dice la regla de la
cadena no tiene mayor ciencia no hay una
magia detrás la regla de la cadena lo
único que hay detrás es una
multiplicación de funciones de cambios
infinitamente pequeños es decir el
cambio pequeñito es nada entre el cambio
pequeñito en b por el cambio pequeñito
en b x el cambio un pequeño entonces es
lo mismo que el cambio pequeñito na
dividido entre el cambio pequeñito en
semi y bueno si hacemos esto ya es muy
sencillo la derivada de arco
quienes día es igual ave cuadrada
entonces la derivada de a con respecto a
b es ni más ni menos que dos veces eso
es muy sencillo este de aquí va a ser
éste de campo ya estoy con multiplicarlo
por la derivada de b con respecto hace
es decir la derivada de b con respecto
hace es igual si b es igual al seno de
ese entonces la derivada es el coste no
desee
éste es éste de acá y es una
multiplicación de ambos por lo tanto ya
lo tengo la derivada de a con respecto
al sen es igual a dos veces b vamos a
ponerlo así dos veces ven que multiplica
a la derivada de b con respecto a sí o
sea con seno de ese por coseno de c y si
ustedes no les gusta tener una función
en el cual la derivada de a con respecto
a se dependa tanto de b como desee pues
no hay ningún problema lo único que hay
que hacer es sustituir a ver por qué b
está escrito como una función de ese
entonces todo me quedaría solamente en
términos de a y desee es decir la
derivada de a con respecto a cm es igual
a dos veces b pero es igual al seno de
ese entonces es 2
es igual al seno de dos veces el seno de
ce este de aquí es 2 b ya esto hay que
multiplicarlo por el cose no desee esto
es 2 ven ya esto lo multiplicamos por el
coseno dc que es pues este de aquí no
había mucho que hacer aquí y ya está
esto es todo lo que hay que hacer pero
antes de pasar a lo siguiente me
gustaría recordar lo que siempre hemos
visto acerca de la regla de la cadena
como usualmente hemos visto la regla de
la cadena que es si yo tengo que es
igualdad de cuadrada y b es igual al
seno de c pues porque no simple y
sencillamente sustituimos ab que es
igual al seno de c en mi primer ecuación
entonces pues es lo que vamos a hacer
ahorita yo quiero trabajar con la idea
de que el seno de se lo voy a sustituir
en a y por lo tanto voy a derivar con
respecto a cm
entonces vamos a entrar a hacerlo y esto
me va a quedar a es igual a b cuadrado
pero sí b es igual al seno ese entonces
a es igual al seno desde elevado al
cuadrado
y bueno si ya tengo yo esta función una
función que depende de s
entonces yo puedo calcular o pensar en
la derivada de a con respecto hace
usando la regla en la cadena la realidad
la cadena que siempre hemos usado y
vamos a ver que vamos a llegar al mismo
resultado por lo tanto quién es la
derivada de a con respecto a ser bueno
si utilizamos la regla de la cadena lo
que hay que hacer es bajar el exponente
poner la función tal cual y bajarle uno
al exponente por lo tanto vamos a
hacerlo bajamos el exponente que es 2 y
lo ponemos multiplicando al seno de ese
elevado a la potencia 1 entonces nos
queda dos veces el seno de c y esto lo
tenemos que multiplicar por la derivada
de la función interna que es coseno
desee y ya se dieron cuenta llegamos
otra vez al mismo resultado solamente
que esta vez utilizamos un método
distinto y espero que en este momento
encuentran la conexión con los dos
procedimientos distintos ambos tienen
que ver con la regla de la cadena sin
embargo es tan importante lo que hicimos
que los dos nos dan el mismo resultado
si si nosotros tomamos la derivada de a
con respecto a b pues será 2 b es decir
dos veces el seno de ese x la derivada
de b con 2
es decir el coste de nótese espero que
todo esto les refuerce y les aclare
mucho más el procedimiento que hay
detrás de la regla de la cadena hay dos
formas distintas de llegar al mismo
resultado entonces es hora de hacer un
problema acerca de derivación implícita
para realmente este problema también era
muy parecido a la derivación implícita
pero bueno esta vez tomaré la derivada
con respecto a x de la siguiente
expresión la expresión ya cuadrada
multiplicada por x al cubo y si se dan
cuenta este tipo de ejercicio es
idéntico a los que resolvemos por
derivación implícita sin embargo esta
vez voy a hacer un cambio de variables
los cuales me van a ayudar a tener un
procedimiento alternativo voy a decir en
esta ocasión que a es igual al cuadrado
voy a cambiar de color a va a ser igual
al cuadrado y ahora voy a decir que es
igual a x cúbica y esto para que lo
primero que voy a hacer es sustituir mis
nuevas variables en la derivada que
quiero encontrar es decir la derivada
con respecto x de que cuadrada x cúbica
es decir d
por ver pero como ahí ves son funciones
entonces tengo una multiplicación de
funciones entonces para resolver la
derivada con respecto a x de acorde voy
a utilizar la regla del producto de
funciones esto es igual a la derivada de
a con respecto a x la derivada del
primero con respecto a x multiplicada
por el segundo tal cual y a esto hay que
agregarle la derivada del segundo con
respecto a x estamos derivando con
respecto a x x el primero muy bien pero
quién es la derivada de a con respecto a
x bueno para hacer la derivada de a con
respecto a x voy a utilizar la regla de
la cadena la famosísima regla de la
cadena entonces voy a cambiar de color y
voy a ponerlo aquí la derivada de a con
respecto a x es igual por la regla de la
cadena a la derivada de a con respecto a
x la derivada de ye con respecto a x muy
bien dese cuenta que yo tengo de
denominador y del numerador al
diferencial de gei y lo podría cancelar
entonces ya estoy aplicando la regla de
la cadena
y con esta regla de la cadena inserte
una nueva variable entonces vamos a
resolver de una vez la derivada de a con
respecto ayer pues es 2 y la derivada de
con respecto a x es justo lo que quiero
la derivada de y con respecto a x
entonces lo voy a dejar tal cual por la
derivada de y con respecto a x y bueno
tener en cuenta que este de aquí es ni
más ni menos que este de acá ya no tengo
ahora necesito también calcular la
derivada de b con respecto a x pero se
dan cuenta p está escrito en términos de
x por lo tanto esta derivada es directa
la derivada de x cúbica es 3 veces x
cuadrada y bueno que sigue después de
todo esto pues muy fácil simple y
sencillamente sustituir ya tengo todo lo
que necesito entonces si yo quiero
calcular la derivada con respecto a x de
ye cuadrada x cúbica esto va a ser igual
a primero la derivada de a con respecto
a x pero esto ya la sacamos la sacamos
por la regla de la cadena es dos veces y
por la derivada de ella con respecto a x
ya esto hay que multiplicarlo por d pero
b es x cúbica por lo tanto es todo
esto multiplicado por ver se dan cuenta
es lo mismo que hemos hecho siempre
siempre sencillamente que he hecho con
un procedimiento distinto entonces hay
que multiplicarlo por b b es x kubica ya
esto hay que agregarle la derivada de b
con respecto a x que es 3 veces x
cuadrada y multiplicarlo por a pero a
era cuadrada entonces 3 veces x cuadrada
y cuadrada y espero que este
procedimiento te haya ayudado a entender
por qué la derivación implícita se
resuelve de esta manera y además que la
regla de la cadena está adentro de cada
una de las derivaciones implícita de
hecho vamos a hacerlo como ya lo
habíamos resuelto todas las veces yo
quiero la derivada con respecto a x de
ye cuadrada x cúbica pero como es una
multiplicación de funciones pues lo que
hay que hacer es derivar la primera
función con respecto a x y multiplicarlo
por la segunda pero esto lo resolvemos
con la regla de la cadena y nos quedaba
210 x de y / de x
a esto había que multiplicarlo por equis
cúbica y después hay que agregarle la
derivada de x cúbica con respecto a x
que es 3 veces x cuadrada multiplicado
por la primera función es decir x y el
cuadrado y llegamos al mismo resultado
pero bueno espero que este vídeo se ha
servido bastante para entender más estos
dos conceptos y si quieres más vídeos
acerca de este tema háganmelo saber con
algún comentario en el vídeo